Is it possible that I am doing too much soda?
Well, it's always possible that we do too much of anything, except maybe prayer.
But yes, too much of a good thing can be a bad thing. So I don't know what how much soda this person who asked the question is doing,
but I remember several years ago, I had a gal who was doing
three 30 minute sauna sessions a day trying to help her detox.
And she was sweating profusely on each sauna. Is that too much?
Well, I don't know. I mean, every human being is different.
So I wouldn't even say that there is a number that we can assign to what is too much
sauna and how we could define that. Everybody's different. I suppose it partly depends on, you know, how much do you weigh?
And, you know, are you, you know, are you losing weight doing the soda?
Are you losing too many electrolytes doing the soda?
Certainly, you have to get argue that there's people that work outside in
Southern climate in the heat and are sweating like a pig for eight hours a day,
laying block or something like that. You can't say, oh, is that too much sweating?
Well, the whole purpose of a sauna is to create a, you know, a detox portal through your skin by you sweating.
So can you do that too much? Well, you could, you know,
end up dehydrated because you're losing too many of your electrolytes so that you can't hold your water.
So if you are doing too much sauna, you got to make sure that you're resupplying to
electrolytes. And, you know, it depends on the definition of this.
So typically if a person's doing sauna 30 minutes every day, that's not too much sauna,
but even at that, anything could be too much for an individual, depending on their weight.
And, um, and if they're in a state of cakesia and they're losing weight,
all these kind of things factor into that. So you have to use some common sense in this.
If you are doing it three times a day and you're sweating profusely,
maybe you need to add, you know, add minerals, some electrolytes to your diet to help
supplement that, um, that might be a good thing to do.
But in general, you can't really do too much sauna, unless you're obviously, you know,
overdoing it in other ways.